la maison conçue par andré vos gentils
qui trône au milieu des sculptures des
lignes droites de grandes baies vitrées
un mur noir et un atelier martha pagne à
dessiner et créer dès 1952 un la
sculpter ici une ses premières oeuvres
parfois de très grandes dimensions je
pense notamment aux sculptures dont
maurice béjart s'est emparé pour faire
pour créer deux ballets et puis là
effectivement travaillé pendant une
dizaine d'années ici à travailler le
bois à ce moment là ici elle testait ses
sculptures des oeuvres flottante
particularité de l'artiste une prouesse
rendue possible grâce à la fibre de
verre à partir de la fin des années 60
l'un a créé une première qui est dans un
musée dans 22 voire amusé en hollande
et puis ça l'a vraiment développer ce
type de l'intervention dans le dans le
paysage est donc ce sont des objets que
je trouve absolument magnifique
exceptionnel de poésie parce que
finalement ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes
sur l'or ils vivent leur propre vie sur
des bassins
la maison est à découvrir sur
inscription les visiteurs pourront aussi
flâner dans le jardin 18 sculptures en
acier inoxydable créé dans les années
1980 les attendent